ben affleck and jennifer lopez pack on
the pda it feels really good and it's
really nice but i'm so happy the love
birds were spotted together in a full on
embrace puckered up just moments before
jen took a flight out of los angeles
that's jen rocking brunette locks and a
brown fuzzy coat holding on to her man
who has his arms locked tightly around
her
so it seems safe to say things are still
hot and heavy in benefit land it just
turned out to be something really
magical between the laughs smiles
canoodling and kiss after kiss after
kiss after kiss
i do love that i love it of course last
month the couple couldn't keep their
hands or their eyes off each other at
the new york city premiere of ben's most
recent project the last duel i don't
know if you are aware of how good the
internet thinks you look it's like all
everyone's talking about lately i think
you might be no i'm not
i'm really not ben um i is it the jlo
glow like how much happiness is she
bringing into your life because you're
looking good man is it the corduroy is
that what you like you're big on the
quarter because i wasn't sure about
where they told me it's fall the two hit
the red carpet and were the definition
of hashtag couple goals jen in an air
vey legere cropped mock turtleneck and
high-waisted skirt with a thigh-high
slit and strappy-heeled sandals ben in a
navy corduroy suit jacket and trousers
by ralph lauren and when et asked ben's
co-star and long-time best friend matt
damon
about ben's new love with jen he had
this to say it's great
it's wonderful and i'm just happy to see
see my friend really happy but the 52
year old triple threat and the
49-year-old academy award winner made
their first red carpet appearance
together since reigniting their spark at
the venice film festival in september
and needless to say
all eyes were on ben and jen
a source previously told et that the
couple quote could not be more in love
adding quote it is like they never broke
up but everything is way better this
time they are all over each other and
their friends joke around about it with
them of course the couple rekindled
their love 17 years after they called it
quits following jennifer's split from
her former fiance alex rodriguez in
april
and the source said they are planning on
spending the holidays together for the
first time since getting back together
i'm thrilled i am really happy
they want to be together all of the time
so their next big things are
thanksgiving and christmas there is a
lot to coordinate so they are figuring
it out and their kids remain the
priority ben shares three children with
his ex-wife jennifer garner
fifteen-year-old violet twelve-year-old
seraphina and nine-year-old samuel while
j-lo shares her 13 year old twins emmy
and max with her ex-husband mark anthony
and e.t source explains that the couple
is enjoying blending their families
quote their goal is to be one big happy
family they both feel like this was
really meant to be jen and ben are all
about their kids and they are having so
much fun together as a big family
everyone is getting along great and
things are really working out for them
on so many levels
[Music]